Speaker 1: Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas
has temporarily blocked the subpoena, which would
force Republican Senator Lindsey Graham to have
to testify in Georgia in that 2020 election fraud,
election fraud investigation. Why is this notable?
Well, it's notable because Clarence Thomas is
married to Ginni Thomas. And Ginni Thomas is an
extraordinarily prominent election denier who was
in touch with all sorts of folks involved with the
January 6th insurrection in no sensible country,
on no sensible planet and no logical universe
would Clarence Thomas be able to make decisions
related to anybody and anything connected with
that election. And indeed, that is what is going
on. CNBC reports Supreme Court Justice Clarence
Thomas temporarily blocks Senator Graham's
subpoena from Georgia. Grand Jury. Remember,
Georgia is the state in which Donald Trump said,
I need 11,000 votes, give me a break. Tried
to coerce Florida I'm sorry Georgia officials
into finding the votes that he needed in order
to win that state. And I know that we are days
away from the 2022 midterms, but yes, this was
all in the 2020 presidential election. The CNBC
article adding the Fulton County grand jury
investigating possible criminal interference
in the 2020 election in the state by former
President Trump and allies, including Graham.
Trump had pressured Georgia's top election
officials to find him enough votes to overturn
the win by Joe Biden. A federal appeals court
last week refused a request by Graham to delay
the subpoena. How on earth is Clarence Thomas
still allowed to rule on anything even remotely
related to the 2020 election? Never mind this
particular case, the husband of a major denier
of the actual results of that election, arguably
Ginni Thomas, what do we call a January six,
sir? I think that is probably the most logical
term to use. He has the ability to block a
subpoena related to the very lies perpetrated
which deny the validity of Georgia's election,
which his wife was doing utterly absurd. Then, as
far as Lindsey Graham goes, have we seen anyone
short of Donald Trump himself work this hard
not to testify? Now I'm going to say something
and we have to take it in context. What happened
to if you're innocent, you have nothing to worry
about. Now, listen, I understand and I know many
of you understand that it makes sense to get a
lawyer if you can afford one. Of course, I would
also take a lawyer's advice and if it made sense
to try not to testify or to plead the fifth,
of course I would do it. But it is this very
same right wing that has insisted previously. If
you're innocent, you should have nothing to hide.
You should have no reason to plead the Fifth. You
should have no reason to try to ignore or get out
of responding to a subpoena. It is they who have
made that case all along, and it is those very
same people who are taking a different approach.
Now, when it comes to that, we saw the Trumps,
including Donald Trump himself plead the Fifth in
a number of different depositions and in different
circumstances. When it was Trump who said the mob
pleads the fifth, you don't need to do that if
you're innocent. All of Hillary's people who pled
the Fifth clearly are guilty because pleading the
Fifth is a sign of guilt. Now they're doing it.
And so, of course, reasonable people understand.
You get the most competent counsel you can to
represent you, the most competent counsel you
can find or can afford. There's no question about
that. But they are the ones who have been saying,
listen, when people don't have anything to
hide, you just show up. You say what you know,
and that's it. Now, if you confront them with
that, now they would say, no, no, no. But sir,
that applies in normal situations. These are
partizan witch hunts meant to get around the
proper use of the justice system to weaponize
that. Very, John. And so these are extenuating
circumstances where, of course, if this was
a normal situation, we would just testify.
We would never plead the Fifth. They will always
have such an excuse. But understand, at the end
of the day, they are hypocrites. All of their
principles. Small government. Less regulation,
allowing states to make decisions. Just showing
up and cooperating with law enforcement. All of
those things are only principles they state when
it is convenient for them. It's now inconvenient.
And now Clarence Thomas helping out Lindsey
Graham, albeit potentially only temporarily.